if you are having certain operations
such as pelvic hip or leg surgery you
may be able to avoid general anesthesia
by having your operation under spinal or
epidural anesthesia instead spinal and
epidural anesthesia are also often used
during childbirth
both spinal and epidural anesthesia
involve injecting medications near the
spinal cord this makes you numb from the
level of your chest down to your feet
advantages of spinal and epidural
anesthesia include the ability to be
awake during the operation and to avoid
the risks associated with general
anesthesia because spinal and epidural
anesthesia rarely cause decreases in
blood pressure and other changes that
might require rapid treatment you will
have an intravenous line in place so
that fluids or medicines can be
administered quickly you will also be
connected to various monitors to keep
track of your blood pressure pulse and
the oxygen content of your blood prior
to receiving spinal or epidural
anesthesia the anesthetist will use an
antiseptic solution to clean the area of
your back where the medicine is injected
to decrease pain from the needle stick
he or she may instill a local anesthetic
directly over the spot where the spinal
or epidural needle will be inserted
spinal anesthesia involves a single
injection of medication into the SAC of
fluid that surrounds your spinal cord to
reach this fluid sac the anesthetist
will pass a needle through your skin
between the vertebral bones and finally
through spinal ligaments and the dura
which is the protective membrane around
your spinal cord spinal anesthesia
begins working almost immediately after
the injection is completed with epidural
anesthesia the needle does not penetrate
the dura and medication is deposited
just outside of the SAC of fluid that
surrounds your spinal cord epidural
anesthesia may be given in a single dose
or the anesthetist may leave a tiny
flexible tube or catheter in place in
the event more anesthetic is required
during a longer than expected procedure
epidural anesthesia takes about 10
minutes to begin working
after the injection of spinal anesthesia
or the removal of an epidural catheter a
small bandage will be placed over the
area where the needle was inserted after
spinal anesthesia you will be kept in
bed with your head flat for several
hours